this morning we woke up to what was
reported as a shocking number 33
33 approval for president joe biden a
disastrously low number and the number
is true
but we're going to contextualize it it's
just one poll and while overall joe
biden's approval is not
great
uh it's still better than trump's was at
this point in time in trump's presidency
so without context the 33 percent number
is not
worth that much
but it is not a good number so let's
start with that 33 number we have a new
quinnipiac poll
and indeed the poll finds
and quinnipiac is a good good pollster
that only 33
of americans approve
of the way that joe biden is handling
his job
this is a tie
for the low
ever received by biden in this poll
with january 12th
when it was also
33
now
the main question for me is
why is it low and what could raise it
really the key to questions with any
presidential approval poll but then
we're also going to compare it to other
approval polls so looking at the
quinnipiac poll
we find that
only 39 of americans
approve
of joe biden's handling of the response
to the russian invasion of ukraine 39
that's a much lower number than we saw
weeks ago
in other polls now part of it could be
the way the poll is done and part of it
likely is a decline
in approval of how joe biden has handled
that situation
um interestingly more than eight in ten
americans believe russian president
vladimir putin is a war criminal
something that donald trump uh hesitates
to say and uh we we will get to that a
little bit later 10 believe putin is not
a war criminal
seven in ten think putin ordered russian
troops to kill civilians in ukraine
14
think that he did not so this is the
quinnipiac poll
well what about more generally speaking
what's going on with joe biden's
approval well for that one of the best
places to look is the 538 biden approval
which looks at an average of recent
approval polls and when we look there
we find that it's not as bad for joe
biden
certainly it's not good and as you can
see early in his presidency joe biden in
the mid 50s in terms of approval
then moving into the low 50s crossing
below the 50 line getting down into the
mid 40s and then into the low 40s and
most recently we see this little decline
from about 42 to 41. if you look more
deeply at the specific polls making that
up and this is where we would say okay
what is where does the quinnipiac poll
fit into this uh we see that
um the quinnip this recent quinnipiac
university poll is here which has joe
biden at 33
that is an outlier in the sense that all
of the other recent polls have joe biden
between 38 and 44. does that mean the
quinnipiac poll is wrong well no it
doesn't mean it's wrong but it does mean
it is sort of an outlier and when 538
applies what they call an adjustment
the 33 becomes 37. so needless to say
this is not a good situation uh for joe
biden and
the question now is going to be well
what needs to happen for that to change
because these are not great numbers the
next question would be are these
guaranteed to be destructive numbers
looking forward at the midterms and
potentially at 2024 well one thing we
can look at there
is how does
the current biden approval
41 point something
how does that compare with other
presidents at this point in their
presidencies if you look at biden versus
trump
you find that at this point in time
trump actually was at 40.6 i mean it's
more or less the same but
biden's approval today is slightly
better than was trump's at this point in
his presidency if you compare biden to
basically any other recent president you
see that barack obama had a higher
approval at this point in time
george w bush had a dramatically higher
approval thanks to 9 11.
bill clinton had a higher approval than
biden george h w bush had a much higher
approval than biden reagan had a higher
approval than biden you have to go all
the way back to jimmy carter to even get
close
uh and even then
just at this time carter also did better
uh than biden but soon uh jimmy carter
started seeing a reduction what does
this mean for 2022 it's not good it's
not good there's really no way to spin
it that feels
empirically honest and i know that
you're going to see hot takes from
uh democratic uh pollsters and
operatives and analysts that are saying
well listen
the midterms are not necessarily a
referendum on biden and xyz but if this
doesn't change it's going to be a
disaster for democrats
there's just no way around it um it is
going to be potentially one of the worst
midterms for democrats in a very long
time now what could change it many
things could change it if the american
perception of the economy
improves between now and november
it's good for democrats and i know many
of you will say but david the numbers
are good for the economy you're
absolutely right but we did a story
early last week about the difference
between an economic reality and a
political reality
jobs numbers are dramatically better now
than when joe biden took over but a
third of the country doesn't think so a
third of the country thinks jobs have
been lost
i know we can say oh those stupid ig
if that's what they believe they're
going to vote on that basis and so what
matters is what people what people
believe uh some kind of satisfactory
resolution in ukraine and it's hard to
use that language given the death and
destruction that's been seen there some
kind of politically satisfactory
resolution will likely be helpful to
democrats because i believe that the
midterms are a referendum on joe biden i
think there's no way to argue that they
are not but not good numbers for joe
biden and if nothing changes that's the
key if nothing changes it will be a
disastrous midterm for democrats if you
disagree with me let me know tell me how
the current numbers translate to an okay
midterm for democrats i just don't see
it one of our sponsors is real paper our
forests on earth remove about a quarter
of the carbon that humans put into the
atmosphere and yet every day we're
cutting down tens of thousands of trees
to make single-use paper products real
paper is fighting back real paper makes
paper products that are truly
sustainable their paper towels and
toilet paper are 100 plastic free made
without any virgin tree fibers meaning
no new trees are cut down but real paper
is super soft and durable you don't have
to sacrifice quality to help the planet
these are great products from a
usability standpoint i'm using real
paper at home you can do a one-time
purchase they also have easy
subscriptions all orders ship in 100
recyclable plastic free packaging
everybody needs paper towels and toilet
paper buy ones that you will feel good
about and they're giving my audience
thirty percent off a subscription when
you go to real paper dot com slash
pacman and use the code pacman the link
is down below